p-put a judge has become the favorite
candidate of Wall Street not
surprisingly the McKinsey veteran but
he's facing trouble in his very own City
but a judge is being denounced by locals
after a police officer shot and killed
an african-american man who the police
say was coming out him with a knife
locals say but a judge cares more about
the presidency than the city he
supposedly runs sure sure we're gonna
allow him to speak if everyone can just
calm down I would love to be able to
finish I would love to be able to finish
my reply if that's okay well a few
minutes ago we show you we showed you
Buddha judges solution to the heckling
he suggested that his own Police
Department is packed with racists well
Harvey Mills is the president of the
South Bend paternal Order of Police we
thought it was worth getting the other
side he joins us now Miss Mills thank
you very much for coming on so is the
department as your mayor says packed
with racists absolutely not yeah this
this incident is nothing to do with race
this is it is about an officer that was
forced to defend himself against a
dangerous felon who used an eight-inch
hunting knife to attack him that's all
the sensitive is about has nothing to do
with skin color so what does it do to
see reckless slimeball mayor impugn the
moral character of cops without offering
any evidence at all just dismissing them
out of hand is racist because he thinks
it gives him a political advantage what
does it do to your average police
officer in South Bend to see something
like that it's very demoralizing Tucker
you know he used the term systemic
racism apparently maybe he doesn't
understand the definition of systemic we
do and that means all he's basically
called all police officers racist and
that is blatantly untrue
well did let me just see of evidence of
that I mean that you would think this is
a guy who went to Harvard somehow he's
supposedly very smart and very
thoughtful and he's deeply moral he's
always telling us that does he have
actual evidence that there is something
called systemic racism in the department
or is he just saying that I believe he's
just saying it I have not heard any any
of that Tucker there's there's no
indication that there's systemic racism
within our Police Department that's
ridiculous
so who'd want to become a cop if your
own mayor is attacking you a national
television attacking not simply what you
do but who you are as a man your
character who'd want the job do you get
paid enough to want to put up with crap
like that I've served my whole life
first of the Navy and and now as a
police officer it really comes down to a
wat to serve the community that you live
in and that's that's who we hire people
that want to help it it is difficult in
today's times you know with with some of
the controversy going on but cops are
good people they want to help people
yeah that's it's a difficult job so if
let's say theoretically that your mayor
was not spending his time in CNN studios
and he was back in South Bend and you
had a chance to speak to him directly
about this what would you say I would
tell him that he needs to recuse himself
from this investigation he has used this
incident to further his political
campaign and he cannot be unbiased about
this so it's so reckless and wrong
Harvey Mills thank you very much for
that update from South Bend appreciate
it Thank You Tucker I would like to
mention if you don't mind we had started
a GoFundMe page to help support officer
O'Neal
however GoFundMe allows an Tifa to raise
money on their site but they have they
have taken down our site
stating that Officer O'Neill has been
accused of a hate crime which is
completely untrue we have started a new
go fund of that yes go fund me yes we've
started a new campaign it's on fundly fu
nd ly dot-com you could search for yes
help Ryan O'Neal calm or help Ryan
O'Neal defend Ryan O'Neal
yeah well that's that's that's amazing I
didn't know that I didn't know GoFundMe
did that yes we're if you'll explain it
already raised over five maybe someday
they'll be punished for it good god
bless you thank you sir